hey we're the cast of never have i ever
and today we are guest correspondents
for wired
we'll be reviewing relationship gadgets
[Music]
these look promising if these don't work
i'm gonna be so sad
tap your lamp and your friend's lamp
will turn on send colors convey messages
and bridge the gap in the distance that
separates you i bought these for myself
and my daughter who lives in a different
state all now whenever she misses mommy
she can just tap the lamp she absolutely
loves it and so do i five stars waste of
money this thing worked properly for
about two weeks expensive piece of trash
one star dang liz
pick a color give me a color
oh
oh that's cool i'll send you one back
oh
cute oh i love this color so how much
money do you think it is fifty dollars
two hundred i'm gonna go with 125.
die the pair okay
i get it with my tray oh thanks man i
would get it for my sister i think she
would like it she would i would not get
it i have a phone
yeah i just i just text you okay let's
bring out the next gadget
i'm really excited oh it is a very nice
look oh that is actually cute very
pretty
the ever me necklace is a digital photo
locket that holds pictures when you scan
it with their phone app this
revolutionary necklace will help you and
your partner capture the pulse of the
time
gorgeous not sure if it was my
girlfriend or this necklace that looked
gorgeous oh it was both of them stan
five stars good job stan
good job stan yes stand room stand and
stand disappointing company i bought
three of these necklaces to use as a
gift for my family to surprise them with
my pregnancy oh wow
oh okay when i went back to them to set
up two out of three didn't work
very disappointing
oh wow that looks good that looks very
nice i have uploaded a photo to the
locket i'm gonna scan it i don't
i mean that's cute send the photo wait
so i just sent it to myself yeah
yeah or are you okay i'm cool it's like
uber but you pick yourself up yeah it's
library
actually make the food at home oh my god
the photo disappears i have to like do
it every time and try to access clothes
that's a lot we
give up
[Music]
zero zero
sorry this is such a waste i'm
going to love to whip
you look great
oh
no
i just had lunch
pocket bad breath tester with an
advanced semiconductor gas sensor this
portable bad breath tester can tell you
how good or bad your mouth odor is in
just five seconds i don't like that i'm
not doing like garlic bread for lunch we
were all just like a table of just a
table of bad bacons yeah
clean making kid brush their teeth
just look at what it says don't laugh
probably a waste of money no consistent
readings think
you just say gum daryl
how dare you i'm trying to catch bad
breath labels out here
two
two one
all right i got mine so what do the
levels mean low is good i think i i got
bad i gotta i got a two i got three real
bad
wait i'm gonna do it again no
countdown
oh
yeah mine was not dope what'd you get i
got a
and you just had gum i have gum right
now in my mouth the best breath out of
all of us
we're gonna try it again with altoids
at least that's not why now i got a
level two i didn't see you blow me no
switch for me no no leave guard don't
okay okay the countdown has started for
science i'm a little four now
me too
this is rigged this is rigged i'm gonna
blow on this so i'm afraid of you
blowing from the gut
this just makes you feel bad about
yourself and whose opinion is this you
know yeah who are you oh you tell me
okay all right
bond touch the bond touch produces
gentle vibrations to replicate your
partner's touch and helps keep your
loved ones close by my love is being
deployed across seas the touches are
vibrant and every time i receive one
from her a huge smile comes across my
face all five stars and it's by let's
get weird
that sort of took a little bit of the
romance out
stopped working after a month you have
to sit there and tap it repeatedly until
it finally starts to record your message
i'm very upset about this one starts
it's super gentle love me i'm trying to
tell you
it's like dying
there it is
very underwhelming
full disclosure i feel like i've seen
this online because i thought it was
really cute and i was like oh this is
wholesome this is not a cheap device a
hundred dollars
is it worth it
no final gadget
the pillow talk wristband picks up your
real-time heartbeat and sends it to the
other person's pillow in your own pillow
you can hear the heartbeat of your loved
one wherever they are in the world i
don't think i'd like that so you got to
put this thing in your pillow i love it
i fall asleep so fast and i would love
if i can still continue to hear my
partner's heartbeat even when i'm using
other apps five stars it's not working
my boyfriend got this for us for
christmas it's almost been a year and it
still hasn't given us one successful
night
one out of five stars i mean that's
their fault they should have just
returned it for another one right after
a year yeah that feels a little odd that
they were like it doesn't work let's
keep trying it for a year
i feel like oh this is background oh my
god your device is not connected i'm not
connected i'm online you are mine's yeah
see mine says you're not online i'm not
feeling this i got nothing that is a
long code you have to i am trying to
make this work this is going to be great
this is not even connected not even it's
not worth it complicated technology is
supposed to make things easier do you
have to keep this connected to your
phone the whole time yeah that's what
that radio pillow seems like it has to
always be on the app even
that's like training your battery what
if the other person lived on the other
side of the world then they're like 12
hours ahead of you and they're not going
to be in bed when you're in bed factual
friendship lamp friendship friendship
lamp friendship lamp what would you guys
vote
[Music]
oh wait this one made me feel shitty
about just because it's a liar i thought
the pillow one was pretty goofy in
theory that one is good in theory this
one is great this oh that one was so
stupid i changed my answer i mean even
the bracelets if it worked
i'm going to be honest
i don't want to wear that sort of ugly
oh wait no i'm saying like no no no no
no no it's okay no i mean thank you it
is sort of ugly like i'm not wearing
that with every single outfit are we
being mean
this is just our constructive criticism
[Music]